e imagina que você está agora em frente
à tela da Netflix ou da Disney Plus e
que nela você encontra diversos Filmes
séries disponíveis ou então que você
está diante do YouTube com infinitos
vídeos sobre infinito sistemas que podem
ocupar infinitamente o seu tempo e mesmo
aqui na plataforma do Ted quanta coisa
legal passa pelo seu olhar
e o que acontece após alguns minutos
percorrendo telas com tantas opções
o exato você muitas vezes acaba não
assistindo nada pois fica solto e tentar
escolher e se perdeu nas opções durante
esse longo tempo e no fim você nem se
lembra do que estava procurando não é
mesmo bom eu preciso confessar uma coisa
para vocês eu sou exatamente essa pessoa
aqui já deixou de ver muita coisa
interessante porque simplesmente se
perdeu nas tantas opções existentes
antes de vocês já passaram passa por uma
situação parecida Vocês conseguem dar
conta
e eu não consigo e eu me vejo muito
ansiosa por conta disso porque não é só
na hora de relaxar vendo séries ou
filmes nós nos deparamos com um infinito
de possibilidades de se consumir
conteúdo todos os dias são artigos
séries filmes vídeos podcast Stories
livros feitos por muita gente no mundo
inteiro acontece que essas tantas opções
que na maioria das vezes ultrapassam a
nossa capacidade de consumi-las podem
acabar por sobrecarregar as nossas
funções cognitivas e atrapalhar as
nossas decisões diárias justamente por
essa ansiedade que nos causa
e a impressão que temos é que nunca
Estamos bem informados e que sempre
Precisamos de mais e mais informações
para tomarmos as nossas decisões bem
esse é uma infinidade de conteúdos e
precisamos as informações para viver e
tomar estas decisões todos os dias mas
não conseguimos dar conta de tudo como
selecionar a melhor forma quais iremos
utilizar
e considerando 30 situações negativas
que acontecem no mundo o tempo todo Como
não deixar que essas informações a fé
tem ainda mais os nossos sentimentos
emoções e colaborem para decisões ruins
na nossa vida e ainda como que a gente
consegue se manter positivos em relação
aos destinos da humanidade com todas
isso há tempos que eu fico pensando em
todas as situações e não por acaso
produzir conteúdo relevante e positivo
acabou se tornando o meu trabalho e o
meu propósito ele dá simples nós
produzimos diariamente um conteúdo que
busca Despertar a consciência das
pessoas para o autoconhecimento para o
auto cuidado para o bem-estar em todas
as suas esferas queremos com isso
inspirar as pessoas a serem melhores
pessoas para se a refletirem sobre a sua
convive
e os outros e ajudá-los a perceber o
quanto as suas pequenas ações diárias
podem impactar o mundo como um todo
hoje e todos os dias nós recebemos
lindos depoimentos contando o quanto
esse conteúdo faz a diferença na vida
delas especialmente em momentos mais
difíceis e desafiadores muitos dos
escrevem falando sobre a dor e sobre o
medo que estão sentindo Outros tantos
falam sobre o amor e sobre a esperança e
sobre como o conteúdo que a gente faz
ali vida simples é como se fosse um
bálsamo para passar por esses dias um
leitor escreveu dizendo que sente que
cada cada matéria que a gente pública
chega ele como se fosse um adubo para
reflexão positiva a
a outra leitora comentou que percebe uma
linha mento entre o que publicamos e a
busca dela por se desenvolver e se
transformar para que assim ela possa ser
uma gente transformadora do mundo uma
médica que trabalha na emergência de um
hospital nos escreveu contando de uma
experiência dolorosa pela qual passou e
o quanto a vida simples a ajudou a
superar aquele momento difícil e tirar
de alguma forma algo positivo para o seu
trabalho e para sua vida não é incrível
tudo isso pensar que com o nosso
conteúdo influenciamos positivamente o
mundo daqueles que nos acompanham é
emocionante e inspirador em Nosso
propósito diário como empresa O Mundo
Precisa da produção e da disseminação de
conteúdo e nessa época tão estranha que
vivemos hoje em dia conteúdo é
fundamental para você informar as nos
orientar para nos proteger
e por outro lado esse mesmo conteúdo
muitas vezes nos assustam e apavora são
milhares de narrativas tristes de
pessoas que perderam familiares em
tragédias em doenças em maldades humanas
isso sem contar as questões os empregos
as empresas com problemas a
incompetência dos governos a miséria a
intolerância racial E de gênero e outras
tantas más notícias que convivemos
diariamente a realidade da vida é muito
cruel e sempre foi mas com a
disseminação das informações ela acaba
por se intensificar ainda mais
e não é só isso nós precisamos também
ficar atenção chamadas fake News que
podem ser compreendidas como uma
banalização da mentira ou a deturpação
do valor da Verdade há estudos que
apontam que as fake News EA
desinformação gera uma confusão sobre a
realidade Ainda mais quando a gente está
fragilizado e o excesso de opiniões
vindo de todos os lados isso tudo gera
um caos interno muito grande e toda
excesso de qualquer natureza ele pode
nos deixar com os nervos à Flor da Pele
exaustos tristes inseguros diante de
tantas informações em 7 Vezes Puxa vida
você deve estar se perguntando então eu
deveria ficar longe de toda essa
realidade fazer de conta que está tudo
bem que mudou não tem problemas
eu deveria eu consumir apenas notícias
positivas
eu não claro que você não deve você tem
a opção de filtrar e escolher escolher
conteúdos que eu mantenho informado mas
que também potencializem o que você tem
de melhor aquilo que acredita e que
busca como objetivo de vida que ajude
você a ver outros ângulos de uma mesma
história e que contribui inclusive com a
sua imagem pessoal mas como antes de
mais nada tem a consciência de que não é
necessário saber de tudo mas é
importante saber como e onde encontrar
aquilo que você precisa Isso tem o nome
se chama curadoria e você pode iniciar a
sua própria curadoria ou seja você pode
ver entrar os conteúdos que fazem
sentido para sua vida e seu bem-estar
para o seu desenvolvimento do trabalho
para realizar os seus sonhos para
entender a sua lição de vida
se aprofunde sim temas de seu interesse
e buscar e desenvolver o hábito de boas
leituras nunca é tarde para criá-lo e é
essencial cultivada seja em livros seja
na internet Há muitos voos conteúdos
espalhados por aí faça também anotações
Organize as suas ideias essa curadoria
da forças ao entendimento dos temas que
mais fazem sentido para você podendo
inclusive tornar uma referência nos
temas e fazer curadoria também passa
pelas redes sociais Será que todas as
pessoas ou instituições que você segue
de fato acrescentam que você procura
para se focar em coisas que realmente
importam e que tenham alguma
aplicabilidade na vida é necessário se
desapegar de outras tampas que não fazem
mais sentido e que não acrescentam em
nada
e outra coisa disse mim apenas aquilo
que que se origina em confiáveis e que
você possa de fato chegar tenha mais do
que uma opinião há diversas pesquisas
que indicam que apenas uma chamada
atraente já é o suficiente para garantir
o compartilhamento de uma notícia ou
seja uma boa parte das pessoas leem
apenas um título da matéria e já sai
compartilhando como se fosse verdade e
muitas vezes não é insisto se não tem
certeza não passa para frente você
também tem responsabilidade sobre o que
dissemina para os outros por fim seja a
pessoa que espalha otimismo e esperança
nós sabemos que essa má tarefa muito
desafiadora nesse mundo tão complexo mas
um bom começo para despertar esses
sentimentos é perceber que a música na
vida
e apesar de tudo existem Boas notícias
Boas pessoas boas iniciativas
acontecendo em todo lugar a todo momento
e podemos escolher olhar para essa
realidade e disseminar as boas ideias
e o mundo o mundo muda o tempo todo
todos nós sabemos disso e adultos que
somos temos a responsabilidade pelas
decisões que fazemos para acompanhar
essas mudanças e que impactam
significamente na nossa vida lá dos
outros e na do mundo e uma das formas é
justamente filtrar o conteúdo que
consumimos e Compartilhamos consumir um
conteúdo que faça sentido que o alimente
apropriadamente é um símbolo de
liberdade Mas também de maturidade
disseminar um conteúdo relevante pode
colaborar com a evolução da humanidade e
precisamos estar atentos a maneira como
selecionamos aquilo que vamos ler
assistir e escutar pois o resultado de
tudo isso um grande mosaico de onde
nascem as nossas ideias e percepções
sobre a realidade sobre a pessoa que
somos e sobre o legado que queremos
deixar nesse mundo
e Sabendo dos impactos daquilo que
consumimos Compartilhamos recomendamos e
divulgamos eu gostaria de te propor Um
Desafio Se você pudesse indicar apenas
um único filme série o livro qual seria
parece simples não é todos sabemos que a
resposta é bem mais complexa a muito
conteúdo em qualquer lugar o grande
problema disso tudo saber filtrar isso
vale para ilustrar a complexidade e
responsabilidade do que estamos falando
aqui as nossas escolhas dizem muito a
respeito de como construímos toda a
nossa vida e nessa época tão incrível
que vivemos em termos de tecnologia
Inteligência Artificial e algoritmos que
facilitam muito a nossa vida é muito
fácil a gente também se deixar pelas
decisões das máquinas precisamos ter a
ciência de que isso acontece e que não
podem ser determinantes das
e por isso a resposta para a pergunta
que fiz diz muito sobre você se você
sabe exatamente o que quer mostrar o
mundo é porque já entendeu a importância
das boas escolhas feitas mas caso ainda
não saiba o simples fato de escolher
conteúdos que te inspirem no caminho
desejado já é um grande começo obrigada